all right
speech
thank you
good afternoon excuse me
i'd like to start by saying a few words
about the ransomware
cyber attack currently impact the
colonial pipeline
this is something that my administration
our administration's been tracking
extremely carefully
and i have been perfectly personally
briefed every day
the department of energy is working
directly with colonial
to get the pipelines back online and
operating at full capacity
as quickly and safely as possible the
fbi
also is engaged to assess the
address this attack the agencies
across the government have acted quickly
quickly to mitigate
any impact on our
fuel supply and over the weekend at my
direction the department of
transportation issued an emergency order
to loosen restrictions on truck drivers
in order to allow more fuel to be
transported
by a tanker we're prepared to take
additional steps depending on how
quickly the company is able to
bring his pipeline back to full
operational capacity
the federal bureau of investigation has
determined colonial's network was
infected by ransomware and it's a
criminal act
obviously fbi released details of the
attack
so others can take steps to prevent
being infected
my administration takes issue uh
this uh takes this very seriously we
have efforts underway with the fbi and
doj
department of justice to disrupt and
and prosecute ransomware criminals
and my administration will be pursuing a
global effort of ransomware attacks by
transnational criminals who often use
global money laundering networks to
carry them out
my administration is also committed to
safeguarding our
critical infrastructure which much of
which is privately owned and
managed like colonial private entities
are making their own determination
on cyber security so to jumpstart
greater
private sector investment in cyber
security
we launched a new public private
initiative in april
it begins with a 100-day sprint to
improve cyber security
in the electric sector and we'll follow
that with similar initiatives in natural
gas pipelines water and other sectors
in addition to companies stepping up we
need to invest
to safeguard our critical infrastructure
that's one of the many things my
american jobs plan is designed to do
i also want to update the people on the
progress that we've made
in our recovery and the next steps that
we're going to be taking
as we learned friday the economy created
266 000 jobs in april
in fact altogether since the time we
took office
we've created more than 1.5 million jobs
in the country
it's the most jobs created in the first
hundred days of any president on record
more than three times the solid job
creation of president carter saw
in his first hundred days and more than
six times what president reagan saw
in the three months before i got here
our country was creating roughly 60
000 jobs a month in three months since
we've gotten here
we've been creating 500 on average 500
000 jobs per month in the first quarter
our economy grew at 6.4 rate
outpacing the growth we're seeing from
other our friends in the eurozone
because of the american rescue plan four
crest
forecasters are projecting we'll see the
fastest economic growth
in nearly 40 years and months to come
we're moving in the right direction
so let's be clear our economic plan is
working
i never said and no serious analyst ever
suggested
that climbing out of the deep deep hole
our economy was in would be simple
easy immediate or perfectly study
remember 22 million americans lost their
jobs
in this pandemic so
some months will exceed expectations
others will fall short
the question is what is the trend line
are we headed in the right direction
are we taking the right steps to keep it
going and the answer clearly is
yes i also want to offer a bit more
detail on the month's jobs numbers in
particular
these months uh these monthly reports
are snapshot as you all know
a one uh so they take one week
a moment in time since this snapshot was
taken
around the week of april the 12th since
then
kova 19 counts are down by more than
40 percent since then and vaccination
rates
among working age americans has roughly
doubled since then this survey was taken
before adults
before every adult was eligible to be
vaccinated
so back then 18 of working age adults
were fully vaccinated today if it were
taken
34 are fully vaccinated
no wonder things in america feel better
today than they did back when the survey
was taken
with that context here are the steps
we're going to be taking
to maintain our progress first
today we're opening a portal for state
and local governments to apply
for the first funds from the american
rescue plan
because states and local governments
have to balance their budgets
a lot of them had to lay off employees
when the economy
stayed in federal state employees and
local employees
when the economy slowed and tax revenues
fell
we're talking about 1.3 million
state and local employees out of work
now but now the money we're distributing
going to be distributed now is going to
make it possible for an awful lot of
educators
first responders sanitation workers to
go back to work
second this is a year-long program
second we're delivering assistance to
tens of thousands of restaurants and
bars across the country
today we're sending out the first relief
checks to
sixteen thousand hard hit restaurants
with help for many more to follow a lot
more people are going to be employed
third the employers bring back laid off
workers
to help them do that we're going to
remind them that there is some progress
they can take advantage some programs
they can take advantage of for example
employers can hire back their laid off
workers part-time
without those workers having to give up
all their unemployment benefits
here's another example in the american
rescue plan
we expanded a tax incentive called
employee retention tax credit
this can provide a recovering small
or medium-sized small or medium-sized
business
a direct credit for each worker they
keep on
or a job that they rehire fourth
we're going to provide real help for
people struggling with the challenge of
child care which is making it hard for
many
parents who need to work especially
women to get back to work
during this crisis thousands of child
care
providers and centers were
forced to close because they couldn't
make ends meet
with fewer students and higher costs to
keep them safe
as a result parents lost support
lost the support system they depended on
for child care
and tens of thousands of child care
workers lost their jobs
in fact there are 150
000 fewer child care jobs now than there
were
pre-pandemic the american rescue plan
has already allocated
funds to states to address the immediate
challenge
to our economy and of too few
child care operations this is the
largest investment
in child care since world war ii today
my administration is releasing guidance
to states
to help get the funds they need out the
door as quickly as possible to allow
dramatic expansion
and availability of child care in this
country
with these funds states can help
hundreds of thousands of providers
reopen
and stay open and provide safe and
healthy learning environments for more
than
5 million children these funds will also
allow states to provide over 800 000
families
for subsidies to pay for child care
simply put
it's going to help working parents get
back to work
this one time investment is
a is a real answer to a real problem or
our economy is facing right now
well look fifth thing we're going to do
we're going to make it clear that anyone
collecting unemployment
who's offered a suitable job must
take the job or lose their unemployment
benefits
there are a few covet 19 related
exceptions
so the people aren't forced to choose
between their basic safety
and a paycheck but otherwise that's the
law
i know there's been a lot of discussion
since friday
since friday's report that people are
being paid to stay home
rather than go to work well we don't see
much evidence of that
that is a major factor
we don't see that that look
it's easy to say the line has been
because of the generous unemployment
benefits that it's a major factor in
labor shortages
americans want to work americans want to
work
as my dad used to say a job's about a
lot more than a paycheck
it's about your dignity your place in
the community
being able to look your kid in the eye
and say everything's going to be okay
i think the people who claim americans
won't work even if they find a good and
fair
opportunity underestimate the american
people
so we'll insist that the law is followed
with respect to benefits
but we're not going to turn our backs on
our fellow americans
22 million people lost their jobs in
this pandemic
through no fault of their own they lost
their jobs to a virus
and to a government that bundled its
response to the crisis
and failed to protect them we still have
eight
million fewer jobs than we did when the
pandemic started
and for many of those folks unemployment
benefits are a lifeline
no one should be allowed to gain the
system
and will insist the law is followed but
let's not take our eye off the ball
families families who are just trying to
put food on the table
keep a roof over their head they aren't
the problem
we need to stay focused on the real
problems in front of us
beating this pandemic and creating jobs
again the law is clear if you're
receiving unemployment benefits
and you're offered a suitable job you
can't refuse
that job and just keep getting the
unemployment benefits
we're also working to overcome all the
barriers that may be making it harder
for people to
get back to work child care getting
vaccinated getting schools open
making progress and all these things and
we need
others to step up and play a role as
well for example
we need employers to step up in a couple
of ways
first we need them to get help to their
people
and get them vaccinated two weeks ago
i announced that we will provide a tax
credit
to employers if they give workers paid
time off
to get a shot and recover from the
effects of the side effects if there are
any
our economy can't achieve its full
potential until we get more people
vaccinated
employers can help that we also need to
recognize
that people will come back to work if
they are paid a decent wage
the last congress before i became
president
gave businesses over 1.4 trillion
dollars in covert relief
congress may have approved that money
but let's be clear
the money came from the american people
and it went from the american people to
american businesses
many of them big businesses to help them
get through this pandemic and
keep their doors open i'm not
questioning it
it was the right thing to do but my
expectation is that as our economy comes
back
these companies will provide fair wages
and safe work environments and if they
do they'll find
plenty of workers and we're all going to
come out of this
together better than before so we need
to stay focused on creating jobs
and beating this pandemic today and
building back better for tomorrow
america the american rescue plan is just
that a
rescue plan it's to get us out of the
crisis
and back on the track but it's not
nearly enough that's why we need the
american jobs plan
which is an eight-year investment an
eight-year investment strategy
to make sure working people of this
country
get to share the benefits of a rate of
rising economy
and to put us in a position to win the
competition with china and the rest of
the world for the 21st century
that's the next stage that's what i'm
we're doing right now
we're working to get that passed i want
to thank you all and may god protect our
troops thank you
mr president mr president you can't
protect critical infrastructure from
a criminal act how can you possibly
protect it from a state actor
you can do both and you will do you
think russia is involved
at all i'm going to have a convert i'm
going to be meeting with president putin
and uh so far there is no evidence based
on from our intelligence people that
russia is involved
although there's evidence that the
actors ransomware is in russia
they have some responsibility to deal
with this i decided who will get the
astrazeneca doses mr president